hello everyone and welcome back to the
Gibraltar Masters 2020 it's one of the
candidates of the 2020 candidates
tournament
Vanka vs. 21-year old Russian
Grandmaster dabit Peruvian and after 10
rounds there's a well seven people tied
for first place but only four players to
go into tiebreaks meaning that a maxim
holograph almost almost made it he's
fifth on the tiebreaks and he doesn't
get to go in into the playoffs so who
people who go into the playoffs are that
with paraben as you have him here with
the black pieces of uncle Daniel loofah
and unrest bank who's been leading the
tournament for for pretty much the
entire tournament however both you find
a CPA who have been eliminated by
vivanco and David but I mean and now
this is the finals of the playoffs
Ivanka versus that would prevent this is
Game one of the playoffs and it's it's
really it's really enjoyable let's check
it out so long how opens with E 4 we
have E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 sorry
about that
and the Bishop to b5 the rule opus is on
the board and the knight to f6 we have
the Berlin defence we have d3 and the
Bishop to c5 Bishop captures on c6 we
have D captures on c6 so all standard
stuff with castles in the Knight to d7
making room for f6 so you can further
strengthen your bond here we have C 3
and now black castles we have before
there is a one game where an a camera
captured he capture Sundy four against
on under debt and in a draw but nowadays
Bishop to d6 is the preferred move
Bishop to g5
attacking the Queen with f6 pushing the
bishop back and now Russia back to h4
also there is a game pavulon versus a
team or a job of where Queen to b3 was
played in the line of was able to beat
her job of but Bishop the age for here
and now there is we've already seen this
variation not not so long ago when we
covered our eyes of Arusha versus
Jeffrey's young there
the disposition has been reached where
Quinta I ate was played by film and the
future was able to win the game but
Quinta it was also played by Fallujah by
Dmitry and raking in the world blitz
championship and the future also won
that game so now although Quinta I ate
one of the engines favorites in
practical play doesn't yield all well
too great of a result however here we
have c5 and c5 is a new move it's never
been played before so as a move 10 we
have a completely new game and it's
definitely unpleasant for Wang how to
face face such a novelty in a 10 minute
game forgot to mention these are ten
minutes rapid games so what what happens
now okay better up to g3 now putting
pressure on the e5 pawn with Queen to e7
and now if you allow capture then the e4
pawn will be vulnerable so D captures on
e5 with F captors and e5 nicely opening
up the file DEA file for the rook and
Knight B to d2 with ideas of going to
perhaps c4 so black prevents that with
nice to be six and now Queen e2
continuing development with Bishop to g4
by Peruvian now making it a bit hard for
for whites to unpin here with
h3 Bishop to h5 and now rook F the e1 I
just continue to put pieces on well as
optimal squares as possible we have kink
the h8 getting out of this diagonal as
its well it's a 10-minute game you don't
want to constantly have to calculate
what happens if someone something checks
you in this game obviously the Queen
Queen e3 now on pinning and h6 now
taking away the g5 Square from White's
pieces and now Knight to h4 here monk
cow wants to bring is Knight over to
five and then maybe in the future ideas
like Knight characters on h6 are
possible we have Queen to f6 now so the
deny doesn't come with an attack on the
Queen and now just from Knight to f5 we
have Bishop to g6 now preparing to
capture the knight and win a pawn and
this is how long--how
makes it impossible for the capture to
appear
bored Bishop to h4 attacks the Queen
Queen to e6 in the now g4 so this pretty
much cements the night on f5 if you
capture it then just captures this comes
with an attack on the Queen and it could
be very unpleasant night is coming to e4
f6 is possible the bishop nicely
supports f6 and you will never never be
able to capture because of Queen
captures on h6
so yeah you do not want to capture this
so instead we have a five preventing
white from expanding further on the
Queen side and now knight Knight to f3
we have a four if if white is allowed to
play something like B B 3 and C 4 it
will really improve his position here so
black black prevents this we had a 4 and
now comes Luke 8 d1 putting more
pressure on the bishop but also it's the
only open file on the board so makes
sense but also it allows black to
capture the pollinate you know it's a
it's a 10-minute game Peruvian already
quite a long time what what can he do
here well he decides to capture the
point he's not afraid of any ideas well
regarding night night characters on h6
so this is what happens he he rises to
the challenge we have Queen captures in
a2 and now without much consideration
among how just captured in h6 point
being that if the knight is accepted
it's it's bad news for example captures
captures a way to check you have to
block with the bishop otherwise you lose
the bishop as well so Bishop h7 and now
Bishop a f6 check this force is black to
give up the route because there's mate
here so characters captures again with
check King g8 and the Knight to g5
threatening check and mate so you have
to block rook F 8 and now Queen to h6
again threatening Queen captures with
mate so you have to give up the rook
rook f7 and now you give up the other
rook as well Knight captures we have
Queen captures and now finally you have
two rooks for for three minor pieces
which is of course the winning but even
better you have a nice tactic captures
you recapture check doesn't really
matter what you play King h8 now Queens
your checks again King g7 and you pick
up the night as well and now it's
a rook against the bishop of course with
blacks position completely busted so
this is in fact a good decision if black
had to capture but black doesn't have to
capture so feel free to pause the video
and try to find it the best refutation
of the sacrifice while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
unsporting rook captures on f3 and for
those of you who just want to enjoy a
show that's exactly what Peruvian plate
grabbing the rook which comes with an
attack on the Queen you don't have an
in-between move to save the night so
Queen captures pawn captures and now
Queen f6 with check we have King to h7
and now you have to you know merrily
continue attacking otherwise
well you just sacrificed a piece so rope
captures on d6c captures and e6 and the
Queen captures and e6 so nu you grab
some points you are very likely to grab
even more pawns and now the knight is
hanging so what do you do here we have
worked to a6 this was played pretty much
instantly by Peruvian which defends the
knight and also after the knight moves
it will defend the sixth-ranked quite
quite nicely so Queen captures on e5 now
grabbing a very important pawn this
creates two connected passed pawns the F
pawn and the e pawn and if those pawns
start marching forward it could be could
be pretty bad for black so Knights the
d7 attacking the Queen also now freeing
up the rook we have Queen to c7
attacking the knight and Queen to f7 now
defending and bringing the Queen back
into the defense and now the proper way
to continue the attack is f4 f4 f5 e v
and you continue pushing as much as
possible and as far as possible because
like I said it's a ten minute rapid game
you sacrifice material you are on the
attack you want to make stuff happen but
here wang hao actually goes rook to d1
he threatens the knight but that's not
that's not really a problem since the
Queen and f7 is defended so here just
nice the f8 and again you have two
choices straight Queens or capture on c5
now it's pretty much pointless to check
what the end
says here the engine prefers capturing
the seaport but not by much only by us
by a small margin but if you're playing
against the human and if you've sucked
for his material black is very long time
his Kings position is pretty much busted
you want to keep the Queen's on the
board so Queen captures and c5 should be
played definitely here now there is
nothing forced here for white of course
for example if Bishop captures you can
continue pushing f4 and now you can
still start pushing some points here
because if Queen captures you get rook
f1 and could be could be a bit
unpleasant for example Queen b6 you
offer a queen trade again you can offer
train a queen trade but worst thing here
you here you you win back your piece and
now after Luke d2 black will win back it
upon it and it's most likely a draw but
still a better practical decision than
for example trading Queens here
monka however decides to trade Queens
Queen captures Bishop characters and now
f4 and now ok he does have these four
gentlemen here and if they start
marching forward is gonna be very hard
to stop them but a3 there's also that so
be captures on a3 rook captures now
attacking the pawn here and Bishop the
f6 defending the pawn this way and now
rook to a4 not easy to find an active
move for black you have to do something
against these pawns and here Wang how
was I think he was around 2 minutes up
on the clock and Peruvian was already
down to some 30 seconds but he did
consider rook to d8 rook to d8 he
calculated it a lot and he lost a lot of
time but the problem is it unwinds into
a draw and it seems that one guy really
wanted to win this game with white point
is that after you attack the knight
Knight attacks rook rook checks king g6
and now Bishop to e5 you have to give up
this pawn but after we give up this
point f5 check or wins the night here
so King g5 you will capture here black
captures here and now after you move the
bishop you're gonna win this pawn as
well and it's pretty much pretty much a
drawn endgame the bishops are of
opposite colors and there is not much to
do for for either sides but seems like
one Howard did spend a lot of time he
so he must have calculated everything he
once worked it not there obviously he
went rook to e1 he defended the pawn and
now he's preparing to put it upon
forward we have Knight to d7 attacking
the bishop Bishop to e7 now putting
pressure on the c5 pawn and now rook the
c4 going after the c3 pawn and here he
five is a must be five already comes
with two the threat of e6 this is this
is how you play this Bank how on the
other hand played rook to e3 defended
upon and this gives black evaluable
tempo b5 now and before already will
create a passed pawn so still he 5 is
the is the choice here but King f2 he
starts bringing his King into the game
we have b4 by Peruvian C captures and B
for C captures and the King to f3 now
and okay the king is not much more
active but your points still haven't
started going forward so and also okay
the King now defends DF for pawn but the
the rook wouldn't capture if there was
the threat of just winning a piece so
priorities so Knight the c5 now
preparing to push the past pawn the be 3
square is now protected but now e 5 but
now if 5 isn't all that strong because
the king is now on a light square Bishop
b5 check King back to g3 and now b3 this
where is nicely protected we have looked
eetu but now rook the c2 again white
cannot afford a for the trade we have
rook to e1 but now point to B 2 and here
you really don't have anything to play
roof to c1 is coming so here among how
captured the knight to put the room
behind the past pawn in front of the
past pawn but it doesn't really matter
as after rook to b5 the phone is
defended and it was in this position
that bunker resigned the game as there's
no defense against the bishop to a2 so
really a really weird game wrong how
Maeda
made a beautiful practical decision he
sacrificed a knight on a six and he had
the attack that the black King was wide
open and if anything he can just check
him for for as long as he wants but
something weird happened and then he
started spending a lot of time he traded
Queens and he basically started playing
this game as if he didn't just sacrifice
a piece with
which you know if you do that then this
will happen and in the next game he had
the black pieces where he had to win on
demand but he wasn't able to do so and
in the end he he got in into a well a
worse position and in that moment
Parveen offered him a draw which one how
of course he gladly accepted as didn't
want to lose unnecessary rating points
and Paragon was very happy clinching the
the victory in this idea brother masters
2020 so so I don't forget here are the
standings after 10 rounds they aren't
correct because here you can see that
the Andre panko is first but these are
the standings after 10 rounds the D
standings do not include the playoff so
it's actually David Peruvian first place
van how one of the candidates in second
place and then as continues under a spin
codon loofa maxime beaugeois graph in in
fifth then david navara mustafa elmas
Parham exude liu yun verily Veselin
Topalov
chopra aryan Michalka baile mullah
Karthikeyan michael adams laQuan lien
going jones
even charge even charge had a very
promising position against program and i
think it was even winning so he was very
close to finishing the time for first
but pregnant and uh you know valiantly
defended a worse position for first like
sixty moves in the indie and prabhu
managed to draw and then krishnan second
in 18th june sort pregnant nonde in
twenty bogdan daniel deaths then tan
jianci
daniel booko to row fernando Parata and
even cheaper in of those are the 24 of
the first 25 so yeah really exciting
stuff and the really big achievement for
for a 21 year old Russian Grandmaster
David Peruvian not only winning the
Gibraltar 2020 masters but also
eliminating von cow in a match that's
that's not not a small thing and part of
this he had he had a good good
tournament in the the Isle of Man
grande Swiss where he worked he finished
in tenth place almost 2800 performance
so things are things are definitely
looking up for him but yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it ended this
very short coverage of the Gibraltar
Masters I will go through your
suggestions if there are any games that
are really worth showing so I will
definitely show them and yeah that's
pretty much it I also I prepared
something for you but let me just check
if I still have it
yeah here just something to improve your
day here is a here's a nice photo of of
Vassili even shook I have to resize it a
bit sorry about that
forgot forgot to prepare this before the
video and Nicky's photos are just so so
huge yeah this might take a while but it
will be worth it there's no shortcuts
here for the head to make it faster so
sorry about that yeah this is okay this
is really weird
I'll make sure not not to let this
happen for you know another time but
trust me it's gonna be good it's gonna
be good it's a it's a you know a nice
photo of Chucky is always always worth
it there you have it there there he is
oh yeah there it is alright so here it
is yeah there we go a nice photo of
Chucky
to brighten your day just with this with
this little cup of coffee you know
obviously taking it with sugar as he
does have his spoon there so there you
have it also courtesy of Nicky Riga
official photographer of the of the
Gibraltar masters 2020 so let's just
enjoy that for a few seconds and that's
that's it so yeah I would like to thank
Michael Squire Amato's railing here and
Michael Scott fellows for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Paul
Morphy saga until the next current event
happens in the chest world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day